الوسط الرياضي في المملكه يحتفي برحله
السعوديه نحو الفضاء وفينيسيوس يصبح قضيه
وطنيه في البرازيل ورياض محرز يحقق رقما
قياسيا في الكره الانجليزيه هذه الاخبار
وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه رياضه اهلا
بكم
تفاعل الوسط الرياضي السعودي بحفاوه مع
رحله رائدي الفضاء علي القرني وريان
برناوي الى الفضاء وزاره رياضه السعوديه
نشرت تغريده دعما على تويتر كتب فيها
للعلياء السعوديه نحو الفضاء فيما علق
اللاعب الدولي السابق سامي الجابر قائلا
السعوديون طموحهم عنان السماء وكان رائد
الفضاء السعوديان ارسل مقطع فيديو اعلنا
من خلاله وصولهما سالمين الى محطه الفضاء
الدوريه
تحولت قصه لاعب ريال مدريد فينيسيوس الى
قضيه راي عام في البرازيل بعد تعرضه
المتكرر الى مواقف عنصريه في الملاعب
الاسبانيه فينيسيوس فجرها عبر تويتر لم
تكن المره الاولى انا حقا حزين في
البرازيل اليوم تعد اسبانيا دوله عنصريه
بدوره اعل نادي ريال مدريد في بيان اليوم
عن تقدمه بشكوى للادعاء الاسباني بداعي
تعرض لاعبه لجريمه كراهيه كما عبر
انفنتينو رئيس الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم
عن دعمه للنجم البرازيلي واعلن لولا
ديسيلفا رئيس البرازيل عن تضامنه مع
فينيسيوس في هذه الازمه
بتتوجه بلقب جديد صحبه ناديه مانشستر سيتي
اصبح الجزائري رياض محرز اول لاعب افريقي
يحقق خمسه القاب في البريميرليج في تاريخ
اللعبه محرز عانق كاس الدوري الانجليزي
للمره الاولى مع ليستر سيتي قبل ان يتوج
بلقب الدوري اربع مرات مع مانشستر سيتي
اخشى ان يطلب ميسي رحيلي اذا انضم للهلال
والكلام على لسان علي الابلهي مدافع
الهلال ومنتخب السعوديه لبنان انه يخشى من
ميسي بعدما دخل معه في مشاده خلال نهائيات
كاس العالم الماضيه وتحدث البلاي بحده مع
ميسي وحاول استفزاز اللاعب الارجنتيني
واضاف لبليه اذا جاء ان شاء الله لن احضر
اول يومين حتى ارى الوضع من بعيد حتى لا
يتذكر فيه وياتي تعليق لبلادي بعدما ذكرت
وسائل الاعلام بان ميسي تلقى عرضا ضخما
للانتقال الى الهلال السعودي
[موسيقى]